[Musique]
nous sommes au salon de l'auto de
montréal pour faire goûter à 50
personnes
une collation incontournable pour la
route la plupart des fromageries en
produisent
on en retrouve partout où on vend de
l'essence il s'agit du fromage qui fait
c'qui quick
[Musique]
dommage argué commenté le fromage qui
fait secours qu'est ce qui selon vous
explique que ça fasse ce cui cui au pays
des dieux pour moi un bon fromage en
grains bien réussi c'est vraiment pas ça
passe par la texture des jo knock on
appelle ce qui explique les raisons
c'est vraiment ce que pour faire la
différence lorsqu'on prend on va sentir
sur le die voit comme un peu glissé
puisque les fromages et en coffret donc
encore un peu humide aussi c'est cet
expert d'expérience le sensoriel là je
fais en sorte que le fromage en grains
voit une meilleure d'une place alors
c'est une culture dans son dos en bonne
compagnie à ce match et au dépannage on
n'arrête pas la peine
enfin dans le pays de celui qui le fait
on l'achète on la mange fait préférer
cette pierre la châtaigne c'était le
meilleur à victoriaville tutoriaux liste
au lac saint jean qui est le meilleur
[Musique]
chaque région ça fromager préféré je
pensais plus par rapport à notre
attachement à notre région soit
d'origine une nouvelle région le fromage
en grains mais c'est un chaînon on est
toujours autour de cette femme pour cent
de matières grasses on va toujours aller
chercher les saveurs de bart decrem côté
lactique mais ce qui est vraiment le
temps de la guerre si on veut c'est le
côté salins c'est le côté vraiment frais
sous la dent
[Musique]
plus dans ce cas pourquoi le blanc il
est plus coûteux et peu salée aussi le
début sa liaison la plus vous semblez
plus allez c'est drôle à la perception
du seul je pense quoi ça dépend parce
que le moins salée des quatre si
celui-ci hockey les autres sont barrés
par le bleu toi qu'est ce que ça doit
avoir un bon fromage en grains comme
qualité selon vous que c'est vrai outre
se couche bien qu'on manque le protocole
de rehab ou de substances plus ou moins
fines il y en a là dedans on voit
ajouter ça au lait pour pouvoir allait
augmenter notre volume de lait à moindre
coût ça aurait pu changer un peu la
texture crois pas que ça change vraiment
le lave la saveur mais généralement
c'est les fromages un peu plus
industrielles qui ont aussi ajouté ce
concentré de l'ordre
mais le jaune c'est un bon taux
d'humidité donc le sco qui était bon
puis y ait pas trop salée est moins
salée votre préférée c'est orange
bush et de l'acier meilleures de ma puce
très mûr salade ni fraîche ou un buteur
comme je sais pas si ça sera un peu
particulier mais goutte comme celui du
dépanneur le job comme s'il cherchait
tout le temps et vous aimez c'est quand
ces températures pièces ou au frigo
jamais température qui est le secret de
la saveur c'est que le fait que le
fromage est fabriquée ne jamais été
réfrigérée lui transporté directement
dans les commerces
selon la loi on perd mais là de pouvoir
le garder température pièce 24 heures
après 24 ans on doit le réfrigérer
[Musique]
et
jamil vaille mois et demi plus sec mais
bon on trouve un peu siècle vous
n'abîmez sensation de bergeron préféré
c'est moi c'est le but j'en ai
l'impression que le meilleur est du
rétro et cherche à ce que pour être
auprès des gens fassent un deuxième taux
à volonté c'est sans même se serait
produit peu de différences sont tous
très bons beaucoup alors quand on
passait nos buteurs et ne goûteuse
écoutez c'est presque ex aequo dans le
coeur de saint guillaume boivin et
rivières mais c'est le premier champêtre
qui a remporté la palme aujourd'hui
c'est lui qui avait d'ailleurs à deux
reprises emporté le clic aziz comme
meilleur fromage en grains au québec ça
ne pas reprendre une troisième fois
[Musique]